[音楽]
こんにちはこんにちははじめしゃちょー
ですというわけでいやー皆さん
ついにこの日が来てしまいましたはじめ
社長の3億円のお家の超巨大改造企画の一
つ
[音楽]
終わりました
計画しててようやく完成したんですけれど
もついにお見せすることができます
はじめしょうカラオケのお家に
[音楽]
作りました
ずっとやりたかったんですけども家に
サウナあったらめっちゃいいんじゃないと
思ってついにこの家のとある場所にサウナ
が完成しました
しっかりしたやつというわけで今日の動画
は
完成したはじめしゃちょーの3億円のお
うちのサウナ
紹介したいと思いますあのねー
めっちゃこだわりました皆さんご存知の
通りもダイのサウナ好きなんですよサウナ
オブザイヤーを受賞したことがあるから
ちょっとサウナが好きなんですけれども
そんなサウナ好きの俺がお家にこだわって
作ったサウナ
是非ともご覧くださいませでは
裏庭に来ました
わかる
[音楽]
あーっと大きな足場が作られているまだ
ちょっとポーズが続いていまして家の一番
上まで行く足場が今作られてますこれ今
うちの裏庭ねこの裏庭の
こっち側ですね
こちらですかこれですか
皆さん見てくださいこれもう全然ね色が
違うんですよこっから昨日全部完全に
新しくして今ここにサウナスペースができ
たということですはいというわけでこの奥
がサウナスペースになっていますこの
サウナ僕がめっちゃこうリクエストして
こういうのでしてくださいとかこういう色
がいいレストラン
めっちゃ指定してリクエストを全部
ぶん投げたんですけども
完成するまでちょっと見ないようにしてて
できるまでは全部管理人に任せてました
[音楽]
どんぐらいかかって結構かかったよね作る
の作ったのが多分年末ぐらいから動いてた
よね
3ヶ月かかってできたサウナですよもう
なんかあのー買って取ってつけたように
なったらちょっと訳が違うのでちょっと僕
も今からどんなものができるか知ってるん
ですけど実物
完成したサウナーゾーンみたいな初めてな
ので楽しみに見ていきたいと思いますでは
見ていきましょう
[音楽]
見えちゃってる見えちゃってるでもこれで
ドアのいいよね入らせてもらいます
[音楽]
[拍手]
富士山見えるやんけはいというわけで
サウナスペースです
念願ですもう念願の自宅サウナついに
完成しました見てこのヤシの木そして
水風呂ちょっと色々見ていこうか入り口が
こことやっぱりそのことがみんな行けない
のでしっかりと柵はしてあります全部柵で
覆ってあるもう外から見えないように水
汲んだり飲めたりするキッチンみたいな
スペースここもなんか置けそうね食べ物と
か
めっちゃやばくない
これは
[音楽]
強い
スイッチで切り替わる最高じゃんそんで
ここがシャワーですね
このヘッドシャワーと上から出るやつこの
2つがないとサウナとは言えませんそして
皆さんサウナーなら誰しもが知っている
でしょうサウナで何が大事なのかそう
水風呂ですこちら水風呂でございます見て
この下に照明がちょっと光ってるのよで
ここのライトつけて夜になると照らされて
水風呂が光るようになってます
最高最高最高最高水温も低くてなんか
大きい方が絶対もうガーンて寝たいんです
よ水風呂になのでかなり大きめの水風呂を
作りましたこれはね相当なこだわり
ポイントですよそしてこれが我が家の
サウナ
バレるサウナです
[音楽]
[拍手]
けども形が見て樽みたいになってるでしょ
これバレラサウナっていう種類のサウナ
ですバチバチの木で作られてるサウナただ
のサウナじゃなくて実は3層構造になって
て中にこうステンレスでギュッとしたりし
て
熱が逃げないように普通なバレルサウナと
はレベルが違いますバチバチに熱いサウナ
になってますでこれ何がポイントかって
いうと
窓付けたんですよ窓これねちゃんと外の
景色見たくて開放感が欲しかったので
なるべく外の景色見ながらサウナ入りたい
なと思ってこれわざと大きな窓付けました
ここもね結構コリポイントの一つこれは
ツインかな
やっぱ形が見て
かっこいいのよ結構大きめのバレルサラダ
に仕上げました
めっちゃ良くないこれでっかいここが
入り口ですね
消えたりします
はいというわけで早速サウンドに入って
いこうと思いますいやめっちゃ見た目が
かっこいいですよなんか普通の形じゃなく
てこういうなんか特殊な形のサウナ3つ
いいなと思って絶対バレーサウナにしよう
と思ってなんか静岡計算の木を使って作っ
てもらいましたじゃあちょっと早速
中入っちゃいましょうかじゃあ行ってき
ますまず普通に入るでも
普通です
まずここが
ここはまずえめっちゃかっこいい
温度がなんと今110度ですもうここは
こだわって絶対コンディションので
110度超高音さらにしましたこれは何
これ温度調節かなでなんとコンセントも
ありますここまでサウナじゃなくて熱が
逃げないように二重扉にしてますここから
入ってきてこの後この奥がさらにですね
こっちが本物ですえ
めっちゃビジュよ
よくない
俺んちよこれ早速入っていきたいと思い
ますすごいじゃあ失礼します
こんな感じの名前になってます
[音楽]
最高すぎんかこれ
ロールしちゃいます
[音楽]
失礼します
いやマジで皆さんこれ最高です待ってー
最高すぎるこれオレンジでしょう家でこの
レベルのサロンできるの結構感動なんだ
けど
[音楽]
結構汗が乾いてきました早汗かくのやっぱ
ねさすが110度そしてロールしたらもう
暑すぎて一瞬出してくれちゃいますね
汗が
止まらないぜ
[音楽]
心臓止まる
止まった
[拍手]
やべえ
全部俺のだやばい
マジで最高
[拍手]
失礼します
あーマジでやばい本当にやばい
[音楽]
ごめんなさい
笑っちゃう
ちょっと待って本当に嬉しいやばい
[音楽]
はいというわけで3億円の家にできた
はじめしゃちょーのサウナいかがだった
でしょうか俺ね今日初めて入ったし初めて
ちゃんと周り見たんですけども
理想です最高
夢が一つ叶った俺のもう本当にサウナに
はまっててもう大好きすぎてサウナが
サウナブームが来るちょっとないかなうち
の近くにサウナ識字っていう全国的に見て
もサウナの聖地と呼ばれている最強の
サウナがあるんですけどもブームとかじゃ
なかったんで全然ガラガラの時に行って
ほんとサウナの予算に目覚めてそこから
もう中毒のようにサウナに入り続け気づい
たら世の中がサウナブームになって
いろんな魚屋さん行ってもたくさんの人で
溢れているこうなんかもう人気でサウナ
ブームが凄すぎる中俺は気づきました
自分の家に本格的なサウナ作れば最高に
楽しめるんじゃないかとそういうことで
できたのがこのサウナでございますいや
もうこだわってるポイントも全部完璧
クオリティの高さ
温度高級感あふれるこの機能なんかシック
な色合いそして外の景色がオーシャン
ビューに富士山にヤシの木最高ですこの
サウナはもうマジで最高
冗談抜きでもう
嬉しいですよなんか後輩とか友達とか
YouTuberとかちょっとうちに来た
仲いい人達とかとここでねなんか語れたり
したらめっちゃいいなと思いますマジで紙
空間だよもう
これよこれなんですよこれがお家にあるの
はやばいってはいということで動画で何回
も言ってたけど本当このスペースちょっと
もったいないなと思ってたのでまさに
サウナにしようと思ってたらサウナにでき
たっていう3億円のうちがまた一つ大きく
進化しましたもう進化というかこれも増設
だね朝らしい施設ができましたこのサンド
もう一つすごいのが実は今足場あったじゃ
ないですか最初に言った4階のあの足場で
4階にソーラーパネルを設置して対応
エネルギーで発電しようかなと思ってこれ
実はかなり
環境にも良いサウナを作りましたsdgs
環境のことも考えつつ最高のサウナもう
100点最後のサウナ気になるお値段お
いくらなんでしょうか
2600万円
[音楽]
いろいろわけがあってもちろんサウナ自体
も高いですけどもこのバレルさん自体は
多分ね300万円ぐらいと言われてます
そもそもサウナを受ける場所とか水風呂と
かシャワーを受けるって事は濡れていい
ように床をプール仕様にする工事してるん
ですよ防水とかの床の工事にもかなりお金
かかったし
柵とか照明そして何よりお金かかったのが
きっとねソーラーパネルだと思う結構ね
ソーラーパネルを置くのめっちゃお金
かかってるぽくてトータルで約
2600万円ってことでした
[音楽]
サウナなのでお手入れとかすごい大事だと
思うのでしっかり手入れしつつ交配させて
仲間たちと楽しくサムの大事に使って
いければいいと思いますこの家そろそろ
総額4億円
[音楽]